the chancellor nadim zahawi is with us
this morning congratulations chancellor
thank you for joining us on the program
this morning um
what first attracted you to become
chancellor for a man described as a liar
a schemer a law breaker and without
integrity
you don't go into this uh job to
have an easy life um
you make some tough decisions every day
um and um
sometimes
you know
it's easy to walk away but actually it's
much tougher to
deliver for the country if you look at
where we are today okay we are facing a
a global uh battle against inflation
inflation is raging in germany and well
come on the us no but it's important
yeah you're asking me a question about
why i'm doing this job i'm doing it
because i think
the team that is in government today is
the team that will deliver that will
deliver
today a tax cut for 30 million people
330 pounds today
as we've moved the threshold of national
insurance up to 250 pounds 12 500 pounds
forgive me um and of course the work i
was doing
uh in education on skills there's
runways for people's careers to take off
on we have a tight labor market we know
that yeah so there's some big challenges
facing us and i do want to and i want to
i want to make sure we deal with those
challenges the people by the way who are
egging us on to divide and to turn on
one another are people like alistair
campbell and wherever as the campbell is
you want to be on the opposite side of
the argument in my view okay so um
sometimes you said sometimes it's easier
to walk away did you think about it
no i'm just saying to you in life
that it's you know having to take tough
decisions as you do
when i was in vaccines when i'm in
education and now in the treasury there
are no easy answers the most important
thing to remember is we've got a task
ahead of us to rebuild the economy we've
just come out from you know what is the
equivalent of a world war ii talk about
the economy let's do it and of course
did you threaten to resign
no i didn't no i didn't threaten to
design at all because where we come from
i wonder i i have apparently liz trust
was going to be
foreign it was good the foreign
secretary was going to be chancellor and
you said if it's not me i'm stepping no
i haven't that that is that is
completely untrue and by no foundation
in reality absolutely by the way
this is a team game and you you play for
the team and you deliver for the nation
okay ultimately nothing to do with
personality our focus has to be about
delivery okay that is the important
personal ambition the no because the
right look
as i said to you sometimes you know
walking away um
yeah may give you some some you know
uh respite uh uh dare i say but the idea
that you have to deliver for the country
i think is the country that's given me
everything giving my family everything
is the right thing to do we have some
big challenges ahead of us we've yeah
we've got war raging on our continent
you know nobody foresaw a war in uh in
europe for decades now you run as leader
when there's a vacancy
so do you run as leader when there's a
vacancy there's no vacancy the people
who are eggiest on to
turn on one another
are the people like alistair campbell
who will never vote conservatives
when there's a vacancy will you run the
odds are really good for you at the
moment ten to one
well first of all i will be working very
hard to make sure that this team
continues to deliver the prime minister
is focused on delivery delivery delivery
um i want to make sure that not only do
we rebuild the economy we've got to grow
the economy um yeah we had some good
growth the second growth fast growing
country this year uh it's going to come
to order it returns to that in 2024 it
grows again in 2025 but i've got to make
sure we get through 22 and 23
where you know we've got inflation um
which can be you know a really painful
thing if we let it um uh uh you know get
out of control okay and that is my focus
it has to be my friend let's talk about
policy then what immediate plans did you
make with the prime minister yesterday
when it comes to
national insurance when it comes to
cutting taxes when it comes to tackling
inflation when it comes to corporation
tax what conversations did you have
during your longer meeting yesterday so
it's my first day in the job uh the
conversation we had is my task is to
rebuild the economy and to grow the
economy i will look at everything
to make sure that we continue
to be on the side of people a tax cut
today of 330 pounds the first tax cut in
a decade
for 30 million people that's really
important 1200 pounds for 8 million
people who are really being squeezed by
this global battle against inflation
that's really important uh and
once i've
looked at the evidence i'll be very
happy to be back on your show k and
share with you what i think we need to
do to rebuild and grow no i've got to
rebuild and grow the economy we've just
come out of the equivalent of a world
war and we've got war raging in europe
because of putin's illegal um invasion
of ukraine we've got to deal with these
big things now i think to indulge in
infighting is the wrong thing we've got
to unite and deliver well you wanted to
move on to the economy so we are we've
predicted to have the slowest economy
growth in the g7 next year and the
highest inflation um our economic um
outlook is just not very good isn't it
well you said so we had the second
fastest growth this year um and we set
to return to that in 2024 the gap is
2023. i want to look at what more i can
do to make sure we can return to growth
the important thing is to get inflation
under control you know be fiscally
responsible well i'll come back on your
program and very happily uh talk to you
about exactly how i'm going to make sure
that the first thing we've got to do is
make sure that you know we
are really careful about you know
whether it's public sector pay so
inflation doesn't continue to be fueled
that fire must be fueled
that will cause even deeper and more
painful problems for exactly the people
we're trying to help with the tax cut
today those 30 million people are
getting 330 pounds of attacks up today
uh will suffer the most if inflation's
going to do about corporation tax i will
look at everything there's nothing off
the table i want to be
one of the most competitive countries in
the world for investment i know that you
know boards around the world when they
make investment decisions they're long
term and the one tax they can compare
globally
is corporation tax and i want to make
sure
that we are as competitive as we can be
uh whilst maintaining fiscal discipline
uh of course working with the bank of
england to make sure that monetary uh
policy is right uh for this country and
bringing inflation under control it will
abate i my task is to make sure it
happens as quickly as possible and to be
on the side of the you know the people
who are really hard-pressed which is why
today's tax teachers like teachers who
wanted a nine percent pay raise well
they wanted more you said that you would
offer them a nine percent pay raise now
that you're in a position to do that
will you still honor that i so the uh
pledge i will give teachers is um we
will do nine percent for uh the the
teachers that are starting in teaching
this year uh seven point seven percent
next year for them what about other
sectors will they get the same and
senior teachers will get that five
percent that i've proposed um and i will
obviously look at the recommendation
from the pay review bodies across the
board uh where we're we're looking at
nine percent and then at new nurses
you're saying oh you can only get three
percent no no but what i've said to new
teachers is i want to get them to 30 000
pounds a year um the public sector
review uh bodies for health for
education for transport and elsewhere
will make recommendations and i will
look at those they're not going to be
even handed across the board no you've
got you've got to look at the public
sector review bodies and then make sure
you follow the evidence and i will i'm
obviously working with my colleagues
across government the health secretary
steve barkley no what i'm saying to you
is the public sector review bodies uh
we've each secretary of state has made
their uh submission to those review
bodies they will come back to us we will
look at it very carefully and we'll
we'll make an announcement due course
what you're going to do about the energy
price cap in october
um so again um yeah
we have got an energy price gap which
which actually does help people what
will happen in october is additional
help that that you know that grant that
mauricio sunak delivered so brilliantly
that will help people with the cost of
energy but of course we'll look at where
energy prices are are then there is a
spike in energy you know that because of
the illegal uh uh occupation of ukraine
um and we've got to make sure we have um
energy
um strategy with the prime minister
delivered by the way um uh with
quasi-cuatang that allows us to invest
in nuclear very very important
investment which
labour decided to
divest from what are you gonna do about
fuel duty
i will look at everything i'm not going
to make policy i'm not going to play
gotcha questions i don't know
how much it literally i believe your
petrol is but i do want to know what
you're going to do about field g it's my
first day in the job and i will look at
everything i'll be delighted to come
back here must have done the you know
the interview process last night when
you went in and said give me the job as
chancellor you must have had some of the
answers to some of these questions well
you know
my track record i hope in government
whether delivering the vaccine or in
education and now in the treasury is i
will look at the evidence and i will
share the evidence with the nation and i
will address exactly what we will do the
most important thing is to rebuild the
economy post pandemic and to get growth
going again
and tax cuts we're delivering the first
tax cut in a decade today i'm determined
to do more uh boris johnson's uh told 80
loyal mps yesterday that it would now be
easier to deliver tax cuts um because uh
rishi sunak is not there anymore so i
was rishi see not a bad chancellor
not at all uh you i'm sure uh read boris
johnson's letter to uh richie sunak and
of course i read
that selected to him
javid uh and rishi uh did an excellent
job as chancellor he's there with 37
billion pounds of help for those people
who need that help because of the global
battle against inflation in 12 months um
but you can't tell me what more is right
i'm gonna i'm gonna i hope repeat one
more time
fiscal discipline bring inflation under
control
a tax cut today the first tax
in a decade um how are you going to do
it so i'm it's my first day in the job
i'm going to look at everything uh every
lever that's available to me
to make sure we get this right
ultimately we are on the side of people
who are at the moment struggling with
their weekly shops struggling with
paying those energy bills that's why
they're getting this tax cut today to 30
million people 330 pounds is so
important and you have told me that
three times no whatever i'll keep
repeating it yeah okay i've asked you
some of the other stuff that you can't
answer but you have promised to come
back so let's see uh whatever you do
about taxes though and whatever you do
about the cost of living it doesn't
erase the shame of this prime minister
defending sexual harassment at work does
it
so the prime minister gave an interview
last night where he spoke about um you
know the mistake that the benefit of
hindsight he should have never
uh appointed chris pincher to deputy uh
chief whip i think
this government is determined to make
sure that
no one uh abuses their position or power
and anybody who has a complaint should
come forward and make that complaint uh
chris pinch the allegations against
chrisman were investigated in 2017 um uh
were found not to be uh right he was
appointed by theresa may as a minister
continued in ministerial office the
allegations uh in the foreign office
were investigated and resolved at the
time with an apology from chris spencer
but with the benefit of hindsight the
premise is right the sex person he he is
right perhaps it was right to apologize
and say that with the benefit of
hindsight it was the wrong appointment
we make decisions
by name picture by nature and you want
to serve as this man's chances okay we
make decisions at warp speed in
government there are no easy decisions
uh to make we don't get all those
decisions right it's right for the
parents to come forward and apologize
yeah but if somebody comes to you and
says this bloke you want to watch out
for him for what he's been up to you
know somebody actually was faced safe to
face with the prime minister
and he did nothing about it and then he
lied about it well first of all we make
decisions
you know you know that the speed at
which we make decisions in government
especially dealing with a pandemic
dealing with a global battle against
inflation war on our continent
we don't get every decision right the
prime minister was right to come out and
say look with the benefit of hindsight
i'm sorry i made a mistake on appointing
chris pincher um that's the right thing
to do there's also but there's also due
process it's only right that we protect
people from any form of abuse or um
any form of abuse of power
by anyone and actually anyone watching
this program should know that if they
work
in government and for any mp or any
minister they can come forward um and uh
if they feel that in in any way being
um uh abused
that's the right thing to do okay that
culture is the right culture to
apologize is the right thing to do okay
we are nothing's ever easy
rishi um both questioned the integrity
of this prime minister do you think this
prime minister has integrity i do i
think he needs to know well because he's
determined to deliver for this country
good to talk to you thanks very much
indeed chancellor thank you